Hey Youtube. Have you ever wondered why
we only upload one video each month? Well,
the answer's really easy. Time
and money. It's fun of course,
but to make animation videos like this,
a ridiculous amount of time is necessary.
Writing the script, storyboard,
designing all the stuff,
recording that aeration animation, sound
design, and composing original music.
We would love to make more videos,
but it's just impossible right
now without a time machine.
We all have real jobs and do quotes
cause our late nights and on the weekends
because it's our passion,
but we prefer doing it while the sun
is shining and make more videos for you
guys, but now you can help us make
more science and educational content.
There's this great new
thing called Patrion.
Patrion is a crowdfunding
platform like Kickstarter,
but it works on a monthly basis
with smaller amounts. If you want,
you can support us with a small sum
each month and we will spend this time
working elsewhere and make more videos.
Depending on the amount you'll get.
Core reward like graphics for
your smartphone or computer.
Our music links in the video
description or our record,
your voicemail message that says
the mailbox of a man called Jimmy,
something like that. Even the smallest
amounts. Helpful. We really appreciate it.
Oh, videos will stay free on youtube
forever, so if you don't want to fund us,
nothing will change for you.
If we get enough money through Patrion,
we can invest more time in cuts because
I make more than one video every four
weeks in the future. Thank you all
for your attention. Lots of love.
All the fields.
Coats cause out.